GETTING INTO THE INFRASTRUCTURE,
HACKING FOR YEARS AND YEARS AND
YEARS AND AS YOU HEARD THE ANKLE
YEARS AND AS YOU HEARD THE ANKL,
ADAM SCHIFF REPEATEDLY WENT
OUT OF HIS WAY TO CLAIM THAT
TRUMP, TRUNK COLLUDED WITH
RUSSIA IN ZERO EVIDENCE OF IT
BUT NOW THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
GOING FOR HIS RESIGNATION AND
JOINING ME NOW, STRATEGIC
MERCEDES, ADAM SCHIFF WILL NOT
RESIGN AND CONGRESSWOMAN TONIGHT
TOLD THE DEMOCRATS, SHE HAS A
LOT OF JUICE NOW, A LOT OF
POWER, DO NOT GIVE UP ON
IMPEACHMENT.
>> Mercedes: I THINK THE
DEMOCRATS ULTIMATE GOAL IS
IMPEACHMENT AND IT MAKES
NANCY PELOSI NERVOUS.
SHE IS SAYING WE MIGHT NOT WANT
TO GO THERE BUT WE NEED
BIPARTISAN TO MOVE TOWARDS
IMPEACHMENT BUT DEMOCRATS FROM
DAY ONE, THEY WERE COAL AND THEY
HAVE DONE ON TRYING TO IMPEACH
THE PRESIDENT.
AND SO COME I THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE CLEARLY SEE THROUGH THIS.
I THINK WE KNOW THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE GONE WAY TOO FAR.
THEY'VE BEEN RECKLESS IN THIS
PROCESS.
THEY BEEN IRRESPONSIBLE IN TERMS
OF TWO YEARS SPENDING HOUR AFTER
HOUR AFTER HOUR, BUILDING THIS
NARRATIVE, BUILDING THIS CASE
THE PRESIDENT COLLUDED WITH THE
RUSSIANS AND THE MUELLER REPORT
AS WE KNOW THE PRESIDENT IS
EXONERATED TO.
>> Laura: I WANT TO PUT UP A
COUPLE OF GRAPHS FROM THE LETTER
OF THE BAR.
THE FIRST ONE, DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL ROSENSTEIN AND I
CONCLUDED THE EVIDENCE DEVELOPED
SPECIAL COUNSEL IN IS NOT
SUFFICIENT TO ESTABLISH
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE DEFENDS.
SPECIAL COUNSEL RECOGNIZES THE
EVIDENCE DOES NOT ESTABLISH THE
PRESIDENT WAS INVOLVED IN AN
UNDERLYING CRIME.
RELATED TO RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE
AND WHILE NOT DETERMINE THE
ABSENCE OF SUCH EVIDENCE, BEARS
UPON THE PRESENT INTENT WITH
RESPECT TO OBSTRUCTION.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
THERE IS NO UNDERLYING CRIME, SO
THE PRESIDENT EVERYTHING HE DID
WAS IN THE OPEN.
HE'S FRUSTRATED, MAD, IMAGINE
BEING ACCUSED OF SOMETHING,
BASICALLY TREES END.
>> Mercedes: THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Laura: AND ALL THESE PEOPLE
AGAINST YOU.
AND ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WAS REALLY MAD.
THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
OBSTRUCTION?
MUELLER TRIED TO INTERVIEW THE
PRESIDENT AND COULDN'T GET THE
DOJ TO THINK THAT WAS GOING TO
BE A GOOD IDEA.
THE EVIDENCE OF ANY CRIME TO
INTERVIEW THE PRESIDENT OR
SUBPOENA THE PRESIDENT.
THEY HAVE NO EVIDENCE OF ANY
INTENT TO OBSTRUCT JUSTICE.
PERIOD.
THAT IS CLEAR HERE.
>> Mercedes: AND THIS IS THE
BRILLIANCE OF THE PRESIDENT,
WHICH HE IS RESILIENT.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT ALL THE
PRESSURE OF THIS INVESTIGATION,
DESPITE THE FACT IT'S BEEN OVER
8,500 ARTICLES WRITTEN, STORIES
AIRED, CNN, "NEW YORK TIMES,"
"WASHINGTON POST" AND MSNBC.
WHAT WE KNOW THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN IN HIGH GEAR AND HE HAS
FOCUSED ON THE ECONOMY, THE
TRADE DEALS, SECURING THE BORDER
AND KEEPS FIGHTING EVERYDAY FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I HAVE TO SAY, IT REALLY SHOWS
THAT THE DEMOCRATS, THEY HAVE
MADE A BIG GAMBLE WITH THIS AND
THAT THEY LOST BECAUSE THEY
THOUGHT THAT THIS MUELLER REPORT
WAS GOING TO WIN IT.
>> Laura: IT HURT THE COUNTRY.
THEY DIVIDED THIS COUNTRY.
THEY MADE POLITICS MORE TOXIC.
IT DID FRUSTRATE THE PRESIDENT
AND I CAN'T BLAME HIM FOR BEING
FRUSTRATED.
HE'S TRYING TO MAKE GOOD DEALS
FOR THE COUNTRY.
MAY BE WE WORK WITH RUSSIA ON
SOME THINGS BUT DON'T ON OTHER
THINGS.
BUT ALL OF THIS HAD THE TAINT OF
THIS INVESTIGATION HANGING OVER
IT.
NOW HE'S FREE OF THAT.
>> Mercedes: THINK HOW MUCH
THEY TRY TO DESTROY HIM.
>> Laura: HE'S RIGHT.
PEOPLE WOULD HAVE -- I'M SORRY,
THE REPUBLICANS.
>> Mercedes: SOMETHING SO
GREAT ABOUT THIS MEAN HE FIGHTS.
HE WAS NOT GOING TO --
>> Laura: FOR THE DEMOCRATS
ARE FIGHTING ALSO US WHEN THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE TO FIGHT FOR
THIS MAN, MERCEDES.
THE PRESIDENT'S AGENDA.
>> Mercedes: IT IS CLEAR THAT
BASED ON HIS ACCOMPLISHMENTS
ALONE WHEN LOOKING AT THE
ECONOMY IMPACTING SO MANY
COMMUNITIES, THE FACT THAT THESE
DAMPING TOUGH ON CHINA.
>> Laura: DO YOU AGREE WITH
THE RECKONING?
THERE HAS TO BE AT A RECKONING.
>> Mercedes: WE REALLY FEEL
THERE HAS TO BE ACCOUNTABILITY.
THIS IS A RESPONSIBLE REPORTING,
JOURNALISM AT A POINT WE HAVE
LOST THEIR WAY.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT THE DOJ?
>> Mercedes: I THINK ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE LEARNED,
THOSE ELEMENTS AND THE FBI AS WE
HAVE SEEN WITH ANDREW McCABE,
SINCE HE'S BEEN UNDER
INVESTIGATION, LIED UNDER OATH,
HELP CREATE AND FORMAT THIS
HORRIFIC SITUATION THAT WE HAVE
SEEN AND AT THE END OF THE
DAY, THE PRESIDENT EXONERATED.
>> Laura: YESTERDAY BASICALLY
STILL EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
KAMALA HARRIS.
>> Mercedes: THEY REALLY WANT
TO CONTINUE CAMPAIGNING.
THEY WANT TO CAMPAIGN ON
COLLUSION AND KEEP BRINGING
DOUBTS IN THE MINDS OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE MUELLER REPORT IS CLEAR, THE
PRESIDENT IS COMPLETELY
EXONERATED AND WE ARE MOVING
AHEAD WITH THE AGENDA.
THE DEMOCRATS CAN CONTINUE
PLAYING POLITICS BUT AT THIS
POINT IN TIME, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WANT A SOLUTION.
THAT IS WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS
WORKING ON THE RESULTS FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Laura: HIT THE ROAD AND SO